we're going to jump straight to T Swift
because knowing very little about Taylor
Swift
but watching what was called Americana I
want to say the documentary I have a
Fascination in the phenomenon of Taylor
Swift and you know the re-recording of
the Masters like some of these these
fascinating decisions with Incredible
outcomes like I'm very interested but I
know very little but I do recall when
the whole football Cameo came into
Taylor's life somebody who is more
attuned to all of these pop phenomena
said millions of people swifties are
about to become very interested in
football and that's going to be that's
going to be a curious development like
where does that lead okay so T Swift
it's funny because I grew up idolizing
Madonna and I think one of the reasons I
was so interested in Madonna was some
part of me was kind of pre- adapting her
Central exist question of existence to
what was going to be my life which is
need
you you're like how is this sentence GNA
end which is as an artist how do you
sustain a career for a long period of
time without it just being a downward
diminishing returns you know and what I
loved about Madonna was that reinvention
thing the ability to completely reinvent
herself brilliant doing it well and she
did it for so long you know and then now
she's in her close to 70 and her in her
like Legacy celebration era you know
she's done in terms of that part it's
funny because Taylor in a lot of ways
follows the same script which is each
album is a reinvention it's and to the
point of now when she she's on tour it's
the arrow tour it's this idea that like
you're going to embrace all the
different parts of me but they're all
very different and they go in different
directions and
and that's part of my identity now so do
not expect me to stay in the Box for the
next thing cuz that's not what is
happening and that's not what you want
so I think it's why when I went to write
fairy tales I think the fact that I am
such a you know also the reason it's in
the Absurd column is because I've liked
it for so long and now I'm so used to
comparing myself to her when she wasn't
even comparing not myself but like like
her moves and things that
now that she's so popular it's almost
more ridiculous when I tell people
like well we did both move to Missouri
for 6 foot5 aggressively masculine
athletic
[Applause]
[Laughter]
men so I do feel like a special kinship
but it's this idea of like like okay how
do I not maybe you're light maybe you're
double as Taylor Swift I wonder about
that I had one of the Camy treatment got
you babe for the Kelly Clarkson she's
like we've done this a million times oh
would that would be pretty awesome can
she deposit some of the
funds of hoarding um but it is this idea
of like how do you make it so not
staying in the box is your thing cuz
that was Madonna thing and that's what I
want mine to be is and that's why
aggressively I can't be afraid of this
next thing when I'm going out with
something so different I'm so excited
for you this was not comparing myself to
Taylor Swift nor to you different
circumstances different time in life but
after the 4-Hour Work
week every pressure including a lot of
internal pressure but every expectation
and pressure was that I was going to do
something in the same category something
with the same brand which I did
obliquely but the 4-Hour Work week four
fell in the blank right kind of
franchise the whole thing find splice it
milk it for all its worth do the
three-hour work with whatever it might
be but at that point and and you
certainly have this
optionality I paused because the
inclination was to rush and whenever
that
is the pressure I tend to hit the brakes
yeah and I'm like wait a
second this has bought me permission to
write another
book this is the time when people are
going to be willing to take a gamble
because this first one went so
bananas I can always go back to the
4-Hour Work week yeah that door does not
close yeah or it doesn't get locked at
least Y similarly if you try this new
thing you will be welcom back with open
arms